[suspenseful music]
Congratulations, gentlemen.
You've both made it to
the final round, which
means you're both
one step closer
to the title of Forged
in Fire Champion
and that check for 10 grand.
When you came to our forge, you
used our tools and equipment.
Now, we're sending
you back to your home
forge to forge an iconic
blade from history.
Are you ready to see
what that weapon is?
Hell yeah.
I'm ready.
All right.
The haladie.
Ooh.
WIL WILLIS (VOICEOVER):
The haladie
was a fearsome
double-bladed dagger
created in ancient India.
The two recurve blades would
meet at a straight handle
and could be used for
slashing or stabbing.
Some haladies even
featured a third blade
running out of the hand guard.
Though the haladie might seem
like something out of a fantasy
video game, it actually dates
back to the mid-fifth century
and was wielded by the
Rajput, a major Hindu
clan known for their bravery
and ferocity in battle.
Your final challenge
is to forge a haladie.
It must be an effective,
working version of that weapon.
You will have five days at your
home forge to accomplish this.
Additionally, each
blade must have
a counter recurve and a
centered, unguarded handle.
At the end of five
days, you will
return and present your haladies
to our panel of expert judges.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck, Steve.
[music playing]
STEPHEN: Feeling amazing.
I made it to the finals,
and I get to make
a really awesome weapon--
a "hal-a-die," or a "hal-i-die,"
or something like that.
[laughs]
Ray has more experience than
me, and I kind of feel like it's
old school versus new school.
Got my blade length
that I want to.
Now I'm moving on the handle.
Every time I hit it on
one side, the other side
bends a little bit,
so it's a challenge
to keep everything in line.
Oh, yeah.
It's the end of day
one, and I feel like I'm
a step ahead of the game.
I only expected to get
forging done today,
but I got a little
grinding in there too.
[music playing]
RAY: The plan for today is
to get the Damascus ready
and hopefully get a
couple welds in on it.
I'm going to cut up a
bunch of steel here.
I used a 15-piece billet.
I've never made a haladie,
and I've never made
a double-ended knife either.
To me, it's a challenge.
Challenge is good.
Even though I've got,
like, 37 years experience,
it's not going to be easy.
[music playing]
I'm going to go for,
like, 120 layers.
It'll give me a
bold pattern, and I
think it'll look really nice.
STEPHEN: It's day two.
I've got pretty much
all the grinding done.
Today I want to get
to the heat treating.
That's the make-it-or-break-it
part of the knife.
This is my first time having
this much riding on the quench.
I hope nothing goes
wrong, 'cause if it does,
I'll have to restart, and
that would really suck.
[suspenseful music]
It survived.
Feeling good.
Now I just gotta do the same
thing to the other side.
RAY: Ready to start day three.
I wish I was a
little farther ahead,
but everything is times two.
So whatever I do to
one blade, it has to be
exactly like the other blade.
And that can be a
challenge in itself.
So I put the first
blade in the jig,
and I can't get it to bend.
So I said, I'm gonna do
it the old school way
and go back to the anvil.
So it's just going
to be a guess.
Whenever you're
dealing with Damascus,
it's a risky business.
And it doesn't always
turn out right.
Nobody makes perfect Damascus
every time they make it.
This is about a wicked looking
weapon, I'll tell you what.
[music playing]
STEPHEN: It's day
four, and pretty
much all I got left to
do is glue on the handle,
polish that up.
Ray is probably doing
Damascus with his blade,
so I'm trying to be
on the same level.
I'm going to hand-sand.
I'm going to add filework
on both sides of the handle.
I'm doing, like, the
really fine detail stuff.
I'm going for, like, a vine
pattern on the filework
just to give it
an elegant design,
a little something extra.
I'm kind of just gonna
freeball it on this one.
It's just about ready to glue.
As soon as I start mixing the
epoxy, time starts going down.
I only got five minutes to
get everything where I want
it to be because of the epoxy.
This is the first bump in
the road I've run into,
and I feel the time crunch.
OK.
I finally get it together.
The glue's all set up, and it
looks like there's no gaps.
I finished the
weapon a day early.
There's always that thought
in the back of my head
where I'm going
against the best.
But age definitely
doesn't limit your skill.
I'm very proud of this weapon.
RAY: Last day.
It's crunch time.
Time to finish it up.
The heat treat went
really well yesterday,
and the blades look good.
First thing I'm
going to do today
is sharpen the blades
up before I assemble
the bond to the handle.
I think my skill set as a
mastersmith really shows up.
I came here to
prove that I could
compete at a really high level,
and I think that I did that.
The only thing
that could stop it
is if my competitor built
something better than I did.
I think it's ready to go.
[suspenseful music]
Stephen, Ray, welcome
back to the forge.
You've had five days
at your home forges
to work on your haladies.
Now it's time to see how they
hold up in our weapons test.
But first, Ray, tell us a
little bit about your weapon.
Well, I made my haladie
as close as I could
to the original type of weapon.
And I made the blades
out of Damascus,
and I think it'll do well.
OK.
Stephen, tell us about yours.
I forged mine out of
1095 high-carbon steel
and put my own kind
of twist on it from
stuff I saw on the internet.
All right, gentlemen.
Your weapons will now
be put through a series
of three tests.
Up first is the sharpness test.
Doug?
Bladesmiths, the
haladie was a weapon
used by the Rajput warriors.
It was designed to have a blade
on both sides of the handle,
and they were known
to be very sharp.
To see how sharp your weapons
are, I will take your blade
and deliver multiple cuts
and stabs to this canvas bag.
Ray, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
DOUG: Let's do this.
RAY: I'm really
proud of this knife.
I mean, it turned
out really well.
The curvature on the
blade is a recurve,
so what happens is the blade
starts in one direction
then comes back in the
other direction, which
gives it a lot of character.
[music playing]
OK, Ray.
I like the design of your blade.
It feels good in the hand.
You got that ovoid
shape for the handle.
And I like also how
it flares over there,
so it stops for the thrust.
I love your recurve and
Damascus pattern that you have
on both ends of your blade.
It's very dramatic,
and it looks good.
The belly of your blade
slashed nicely on the canvas,
and it allowed
for a good thrust.
And this blade will cut.
Good job.
Thank you.
Stephen, you're up next.
You ready?
Hell yeah.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[music playing]
STEPHEN: Going up against
a master bladesmith
with 30 years'
experience is definitely
a little nerve-racking for me.
But I'm pretty sure
I got everything
executed perfectly on it.
Well, Stephen, we
have a big problem here.
What's the problem?
We specifically asked for
a recurve on each blade.
These blades are not recurve.
They're simply curved.
We put that specifically
on the parameters
so that both blades
are equal and fair
in all the tests that we do.
Your blade does not have
that S-shape recurve
that we're looking for.
Because you don't have that
S-shape recurve that we
needed for the
parameters, we cannot
move on to test your blade.
Well, Stephen, the
devil's in the details.
The blade parameters
were very specific.
We asked for counter recurve
blades on your haladie.
You didn't deliver that.
Therefore, since
your weapon cannot be
tested fairly and
evenly, I must ask
you to please leave the forge.
I'm feeling a little bummed.
I put in all that
hard work and then
didn't even get to test it.
I still feel really
proud of my work.
It's just I failed to see
that one small detail,
and that led me to losing.
I learned I gotta follow the
instructions a little better.
Ray, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire Champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
[applause]
Thank you.
It's a good
looking weapon, sir.
Thank you.
DOUG: I love your
Damascus pattern.
Really, really nice recurve
through it, beautiful shape.
WIL: How you feel right now?
Feeling really good.
Being Forged in Fire
Champion, it's really nice,
especially at my age.
I'd have felt a
lot better about it
if they could've did the
cutting contest and everything
with his blade also.
But I just sold a
knife for 10,000 bucks.
That's the best part.
[music playing]